ja und mein thema heute ist friedrich
mehr hat sich dachte nicht dass ich das
noch mal sagen würde denn das war ein
politiker ein mann der wirklich aus der
zeit gefallen war er war dem brauchte
die cdu eigentlich nicht mehr aber
friedrich merz ist im niemand in der cdu
passt besser in diese zeit als friedrich
merz und das hat vor allen dingen mit
unserem land zu tun mit einer tiefen
sehnsucht nach der vergangenheit nämlich
nach dem vergangenen nach wetten dass zb
nach thomas gottschalk mit seinen langen
locken aber ganz genau so natürlich und
viel ernster nach einer zeit ohne corona
krise ohne klimakrise und friedrich merz
ist irgendwie dieses versprechen dass es
diese gute alte zeit noch mal geben
könnte es ist das sofa was man schon vor
die tür gestellt hat dass so ein
bisschen verstaubt ausgesessen ist und
was man zurück ins wohnzimmer verschieb
und sich plötzlich wieder wohlfühlt das
alte sofa ist zurück man kann sich
einfach wieder wohlfühlen zu hause es
ist wieder alles so wie es mal war es
wird doch alles wieder gut in
deutschland und deswegen ist friedrich
merz die zukunft der cdu der richtige
mann zur richtigen zeit ja nichts gegen
thomas gottschalk lieferte waren sie
behaupten dass nichts gegen thomas
gottschalk im gegenteil um es mit udo
lindenberg zu formulieren der kreis ist
heiß aber
jetzt bei friedrich merz ist kein kreis
und ich finde es diese nostalgie
verklärung ist das ein bisschen zu weit
gegangen nostalgie ist ja das heroin des
alters aber ich glaube dass friedrich
merz mehr ist als nur eine art nostalgie
programm er ist auch einer der immer
noch die grundsätze einer cdu verkörpert
oder man könnte auch sagen er verkörpert
eine cdu wonach cdu 30 wo draufsteht
und ich glaube was was bei friedrich
merz auch für mich jetzt persönlich eine
eine positive sache ist ist dass er in
der wirtschaft gearbeitet hat dass er
weiß wie man geld verdienen muss nicht
nur wie man geld ausgeben kann bei
heuschrecken erkennt ja gut ich meine
das sind diese politik funktioniert so
gut weil die opposition sofort die
regierung sofort sich soft mit der
opposition spricht auch für eine
schuldige weise da hoch motiviert sein
da sind diese polemische sprüche aber
ich sage dass diese finanzindustrie ist
eine wichtige industrie und herr merz
hat doch eine wichtige funktion glaubt
nein ich glaube das ist eine gute idee
für mich persönlich wichtig aber ich
weiß nicht darf man das sagen ich halte
da sagst nicht weiter ich finde einfach
norbert röttgen so dennig
cdu-vorsitzende welt der ist für mich
jetzt zu stark ein karrierepolitiker der
in der cdu ist aber immer etwas mit der
spd geliebäugelt hat um seine
wahlchancen dazu optimieren da ist mit
der prinzipientreue zum teil auch etwas
sperrige friedrich merz für die
erneuerung die rückbesinnung der cdu der
bessere mann und dem dem letzten satz
muss ich sagen dem stimme ich wirklich
zu ich glaube auch dass wir dich märz
ein guter cdu-vorsitzender wäre außerdem
wurden wollen auch bei den größeren
parteien sich etwas besser profilieren
und vielleicht schließt die cdu nach
rechts wieder ab da kann wie die afg
wirklich verabschieden das wäre mir
persönlich sehr recht und können sagen
wir haben eine große konservative
volkspartei dass die cdu wäre gerne auch
mit krieg märz als vorsitzenden und kein
sozialdemokratischen kurs und sie ist
hab ich dachte die sozialdemokraten dann
einfacher wenn sie einen friedrich merz
haben bei bei frau merkel haben sich am
schluss auch nicht mehr gewusst ob das
schon spd ist und auch armin laschet
hatte im wahlkampf höchste wie soll ich
sagen wahlverwandtschaften durchblicken
lassen bringt doch auch der spd etwas
wenn sie hier eine profilierte die cdu
hat also bei armin laschet wusste ich
auch nicht verstand aber ich denke auch
dass mit friedrich merz in jedem fall
klar sein wird wofür die cdu steht und
es ist auch klar dass sie sich für ein
anderes programm steht als die spd dann
ich sehe das ganz anders also ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen also ich bin fan
davon der cdu irgendwelche tipps zu
geben sie haben gesagt herr merz der
schienen old fashion ich würde sagen er
ist old fashion die junge union sagt
zeit für junge köpfe und ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass sie damit
friedrich merz meint muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen also da wäre dann
irgendwie der falsche slogan gewährt
gewählt worden also das kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen wir reden jetzt
übrigens zum ersten mal die union in
diesem tag werden eben darüber
gesprochen dass die mögliche ampel
regierung gerade dabei ist zu versuchen
diese pandemie irgendwie zu bewältigen
irgendwie aufzuhalten wir haben über
forderungen gesprochen politische jetzt
reden wir einmal für die union mit einer
personaldebatte und ich glaube davon
haben die bürgerinnen untersagt aber das
habe ich mir jetzt ausgesucht das ist
jetzt ungerecht dass der cdu also
mitbringen was ihnen gerade beschäftigt
heißt das in der davis mitbringen und
jetzt sei der habe kein anderes mit
briefen hat warum brechen da für mich
weil die union mit nichts anderem
beschäftigt als mit dieser
personaldebatte obwohl sie
geschäftsführend im amt ist gerade und
eigentlich diese corona pandemie
bewältigen ist und darum hat es ja auch
das wahlergebnis bekommen ja aber ich
finds echt sagt ein bisschen konsequent
muss ich sagen die grünen und die fdp
habe mir das beste jungen erst wieder
ergebnis erreicht und wenn man dann als
union versucht einen anderen weg zu
gehen indem man einen 66 jährigen sowie
kollegen im haus sitzt jens toll trieben
der ist jetzt bis zum wochenende hat
einfach mal darauf hingewiesen dass ja
die jungwähler volatil sind also die fdp
und grünen müssen sich weiter anstrengen
weil sondern 4 1 ist vielleicht die
union aber ich wehre mich nachher etwas
geht die schon etwas wie soll ich sagen
aufkeimende autos diskriminierung nur
weil einer 66 ist udo jürgens mit 66
jahren fängt das leben an das
durchschnittsalter geht immer nach oben
und ich sage noch etwas das alter einer
person hängt nicht primär vom
biologischen alter ich kenne sehr viele
jung gebliebene 60-jährige die viel
moderner viel schlauer sind als mancher
prüfer kreis der 30 jährige und deshalb
muss ich sagen was das wichtigste ist
aber in dem punkt haben sie recht
permanent diese kopfsalat dass man da
nur über die menschen trete das bringt
nichts ich glaube es ist wichtig dass
die cdu
ferndiagnose dass die sich auch
inhaltlich wieder zurück besinnt auf die
grundsätze der erfolgreichen cdu
marktwirtschaft soziale marktwirtschaft
eigenverantwortung
klassische rechtsstaatliche tugenden
nicht war auch recht und ordnung ganz
wichtige dinge kriminalitätsbekämpfung
und da ist friedrich merz einfach voll
drin in diesem wertegerüst eigenes
klassischen cd und sie sollen den doch
auch doof finden und sie sollen den doch
auch richtig doof finden sie sollen doch
streiten miteinander und deswegen
braucht es auch friedlicher als im
moment
ja aber der wird schon schwierig er wird
ihnen ganz oft recht geben und ihnen
sowieso herald ja da sind die da sind
die linien die verschwimmen schon
zwischen ihnen bei friedrich merz ist
das ganz klare kante und das ist was was
die cdu jetzt erst recht in der
opposition braucht deswegen der richtige
mann noch einsatz sie sagen wir haben
das mit der modernität gerade gesagt
herr köppel ich würde ja sagen
deutschland ist halt gar nicht so modern
wie es die liberalen und die grünen vor
allen dingen wollen deutschland will die
mehrheit vielleicht gar nicht so viel
erneuerung wie sie das sich wünschen
sondern die wollen eben alte zeit zurück
die wollen im grunde dass alles so
bleibt wie es ist und da ist es
natürlich ein großes oder das hat vielen
menschen die weihnachten ja aber das
angemessen das ist für mich jetzt fast
ein bisschen zu defensiv formuliert ich
glaube es gibt da haben sie recht es
gibt eine sehnsucht nach dem
verlässlichen auch den bewährten wenn
man so will nach dem aufgeklärt
konservativ nicht einfach quasi die
vergangenheit weil es die vergangenheit
ist und wir haben viel zu viel zeitgeist
viel zu viel postmoderne krümpel der uns
da sozusagen angeboten wird und märz
verkörpert durch noch oberste umsetzen
kann in der politik wissen wir nicht ob
der körper zumindest dieses bewährte
klassische
traditionelle cdu bild und
verschwindet außerdem mit führenden
konservativen verkörpert mehr hat jetzt
nicht nur sehr wenig alte unsoziale
politik ja und übrigens nicht für einen
verantwortung also ich finde überhaupt
ehrlich gesagt noch die und nur nicht
vor anfang steht schauen wir mal zum
beispiel zum thema sterbehilfe in
deutschland kann man selbst wenn man
todkrank im hospiz liegt und nicht mehr
kann wenn man medikamente bekommt und
trotzdem atmet hat darf man nicht selbst
entscheiden dass man sterben möchte oder
die union sich dagegen werks abtreibung
ist auch ein anderes thema langners
gegen die abtreibung die union ist auf
jeden fall gegen es in jedem fall gegen
die aufhebung des werbeverbots also um
eine selbstbestimmte entscheidung von
frauen
nobody's perfect
noch eine fdp die leute doch nicht mehr
das hat mich sind beide